[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportages et d'analyse sur Public Sénat
on veut donner du sens à l'actualité
avec nos experts en leur proposant
chaque soir du temps du temps pour
décortiquer les thèmes que l'on choisit
avec deux débats comme tous les soirs
l'actu pour commencer et cette pénurie
d'essence qui gagne du terrain un tiers
des stations françaises touchées selon
le gouvernement qui va débloquer les
stocks stratégiques qu'Emmanuel Macron
s'est voulu rassurant cet après-midi
affirmant que les négociations étaient
en bonne voie l'exécutif a-t-il réagi
trop tard la grève lancée par la CGT
chez Total énergie est-elle une grève
politique réponse dans une minute et
puis pour notre débat volontairement
décalé de l'actualité du jour débat de
société on plonge dans les eaux troubles
des cyber-attaques de plus en plus
nombreuses de plus en plus coûteux de
plus en plus dangereuse aussi surtout à
l'hôpital
les écrans étaient noirs des
urgentistes vous savez même plus quel
patient ils avaient dans les lits et il
ne savaient plus quelle prise en charge
y avait donc fallait absolument qu'on
sécurise les soins qui sont ces
délinquants comment se protéger pourquoi
la guerre en Ukraine ouvre une nouvelle
ère dans les cyber-attaques ne ratez pas
les explications de nos experts dans 45
minutes mais d'abord on vous raconte
l'histoire d'une grève préventive aux
conséquences socialement inflammable
Cécile Sixou des fils de voiture dès les
premières heures de la matinée la
situation est critique en région
parisienne et dont les départements des
Hauts-de-France auprès de 50% des
stations services sont partiellement à
sec en France en moyenne 30% ne sont
plus réapprovisionnés une situation de
plus en plus compliquée pour beaucoup de
Français qui ont besoin de carburant
pour travailler moi j'ai une entreprise
donc j'ai déjà deux camionnettes qui
sont bloqués au dépôt et puis là je suis
sous réserve donc il faut absolument que
je fasse le plein quoi
on fait avec et on compose pour le
moment les grèves dans les raffineries
totales et sceaux entamées il y a des
jours se poursuivent les syndicats
demandent une augmentation de 10% des
salaires donc 7% pour compenser
l'inflation et 3% pour les bénéfices
engrangés par leur groupe ils n'ont pas
répondu au satisfaction des salariés
notamment en termes de prime de
reconnaissance par rapport bénéfice
dans le groupe pour rappel l'un de ces
409 millions d'euros réalisés sur six
mois et on considère que 3000 euros
c'est pas satisfaisant par rapport au
profit qui sont réalisés des discussions
sur les salaires entre syndicats et
direction des groupes pétroliers étaient
initialement prévus en novembre mais les
syndicats ont lancé un mouvement social
avant Gabriel Attal le ministre délégué
au compte public critique la méthode et
dénonce une grève préventive qui est des
idées de négociations une décision et
que des syndicats disent on n'est pas
d'accord avec la décision on fait grève
pour la contester moi je l'entends
parfaitement là en l'occurrence il y a
des discussions qui étaient annoncées on
a demandé à total de les anticiper donc
elles vont démarrer plutôt que prévu dès
ce mois-ci je crois que c'est aussi le
cas chez Esso et donc dans ces
conditions là moi il me semble curieux
de pas attendre le que les discussions
se soient nouées et qu'une décision
était prise en tout cas proposée au
syndicat le gouvernement a promis de
tout faire pour débloquer la situation
avant la fin de la semaine
alors c'est surtout la gestion politique
des conséquences de cette grève que l'on
va analyser avec impossible effet domino
sur la grogne sociale et les
revendications salariales et je vous
présente mes invités mais ils appels ski
bonsoir bienvenue Emilie communicante
fondatrice de l'agence Émilie conseil
Catherine tricot la directrice de la rue
du Regard bon soirée et bienvenue Jean
Gary historien François Jean bienvenue
président du comité de l'histoire
parlementaire et vous publiez il est
tout chaud il se rappelle des presses
chez Tallandier Élisée contre Matignon
le couple infernal il est tellement
touchant que je l'ai en mal on a pas eu
le temps de le préparer en infographie
en tout cas on est heureux de vous
recevoir Mathieu croissantoïse politique
bonsoir Mathieu et bienvenue à vous je
rappelle quelques chiffres chiffres du
ministère de la transition énergétique
30% des stations services touchées en
France avec des disparités on l'a vu
dans le reportage selon les les régions
55% dans les hauts de France 45% en
Île-de-France ces chiffres et mise à
palski il s'explique aussi par notre
inquiétude de consommateur et et de
citoyens la peur de de manquer de
carburant qui entraîne une
surconsommation il nous manque 10 litres
12 litres on y retourne quand même enfin
tous ces comportements là on les on les
a et on les partage avec nos
téléspectateurs donc il y a pas de leçon
à donner ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que malgré il y a eu plein de messages
rassurant la parole politique elle a du
mal à peser dans un contexte comme
celui-là en fait c'est une difficulté il
y a cette difficulté là en terme de
communication c'est à dire que plus on
en parle plus on dit qu'il y a une
pénurie plus les gens vont aller
chercher des bidons ou en tout cas faire
le plein à titre préventif donc il y a
cette difficulté après je pense qu'il y
a l'autre difficulté pour le
gouvernement c'est compliqué d'en parler
on est quand même à l'Assemblée sur le
budget alors il peut y avoir un petit
peu cette négociation parce qu'on
commence à parler de taxes sur les super
profits évidemment l'opposition ça fait
plusieurs semaines il y a eu la taxe
européenne sur les énergéticiens on se
souvient quand même d'Emmanuel Macron
qui parlaient pendant le covid des
profiteurs de guerre en parlant des
assureurs donc il y a quand même cette
espèce de petite musique de se dire bah
s'il y en a qui s'en mettent plein les
poches on peut imaginez qu'on partage
davantage les richesses il y a cette
musique qui s'installe un largement et
je pense qu'à côté de ça il y a aussi un
rapport au travail on sait que bon si on
enlève un petit peu la crise énergétique
mais on était plutôt en période de
pénurie d'emploi puisque on a un taux de
chômage très bas et donc les salariés
sont plus en demande de conditions de
travail de salaire ils sont plus en
rapport de force positif pour eux donc
ça fait beaucoup d'éléments pour le
gouvernement et c'est comme si vous
voulez pas ouvrir la boîte de Pandore en
se disant bah si on a l'impression qu'on
lâche un petit peu là dessus ça risque
d'être la contamination dans plein
d'autres secteurs professionnels ce
conflit il est intéressant à plus d'un
titre et on va détailler un peu ces
différents ces différents enjeux
ensemble Catherine tricolagrave dans les
raffineries totales elle a démarré on le
mardi 27 septembre ça fera donc deux
semaines demain est-ce qu'il y a eu un
manque de réaction qui retard à
l'allumage du gouvernement oui moi je
pense qu'ils auraient ils espéraient que
ça allait se tasser se régler sans faire
trop de dégâts parce
de Gap et puis le troisième point c'est
qu'en fait ça vient au moment où la
question 2 du coup de la vie et la
question des salaires et devenue une
question nationale tout le monde ne
parle que de ça et juste titre face à
face à une inflation qui est toujours la
question des ouvriers de enfin des gars
qui travaillent dans les raffineries de
Total ou d'exon tout le monde se plaint
des petits salaires en France et c'est
tellement vrai qu'on a du mal à recruder
des profs des infirmières des
conducteurs pour les transports
d'enfants des transports scolaires etc
en fait tous les secteurs sont en
déficit et donc là la question
d'augmenter les salaires devient une
question qui qui court et qui est
centrale et donc le gouvernement
d'espérer que ça ferait pas trop de
bruit pour l'instant c'est raté Jean
Garry peut-être votre analyse un peu
génial parce que il y a un argument qui
consiste là on est en train de dire le
retard à l'allumage au gouvernement
aurait pu s'en charger sauf qu'il y a
quand même un dialogue social au sein de
ces entreprises quoi il faut peut-être
lui laisser un tout petit peu le temps
de de s'installer moi il me semble que
on aurait tort se focaliser sur les
réactions du gouvernement là en
l'occurrence ce qui compte c'est
finalement cet aspect très archaïque du
dialogue social en France c'est-à-dire
que vous avez une direction qui
manifestement n'entend pas et n'entend
pas suffisamment les revendications
assez finalement logique de de ceux qui
les prospère puis d'un autre côté un
syndicat notamment la CGT qui dans cette
stratégie de de greffe préventive se
situe à mon sens aussi dans quelque
chose d'assez archaïque c'est
impossibilité ou en tout cas cette
difficulté du dialogue social en France
si on consomme de jeu de rôle le pays
européen ce que vous diriez ce jeu de
rôle oui souvent localement au sein des
entreprises dans les PME ou des
entreprises de taille intermédiaires les
syndicats CGT y compris
nationale alors il y a des élections
professionnelles qui se profilent il y a
les chances de la manifestation du 16
octobre il y a des choses aussi qui se
construisent par rapport au calendrier
politique non mais je termine ce que je
veux dire et en même temps moi c'est ce
qui m'intéresse en tant qu'historien
c'est qu'il y a à mon sens je pense que
c'est ça révèle à quel point notre
dialogue social reste encore un peu
archaïque alors et en même temps quelque
chose de très nouveau qui est comme une
sorte de nouvelle révolution sociale
c'est-à-dire cet exigence légitime des
travailleurs a obtenir des le partage
des richesses mais je le répète ça ne
doit pas non plus oblitérer et nous
empêcher de voir la responsabilité de du
directeur de du président Directeur de
Total je peux pas qu'elles sont titres
et des syndicats qui à mon sens là aussi
sont pas forcément sur le climat social
et sur les leçons générales on y
reviendra je vous promet dans un dans un
chapitre mais Mathieu je voudrais bien
vous entendre peut-être justement sur
cette gestion de crise on va on va
rester concentré un peu là dessus
un condensé de ce qu'il faut pas faire
d'une certaine façon sous-estimation du
risque manque d'anticipation
une a dit négation de la réalité ou déni
de réalité retard dans la réaction là en
fait tous les ingrédients d'un combo
perdant en 10 jours de temps la
situation s'est dégradé sans que les
ministres concernés ne semble prendre la
mesure du problème écoutez par exemple
ce que disait Olivier Véran à la sortie
du Conseil ministre c'était mercredi
dernier
je vous ai donné les chiffres nous ne
sommes pas en situation pénurie mais il
y a des tensions elles sont temporaires
nous pouvons les expliquer et nous
estimons que tout est mis sur la table
pour faire en sorte qu'elle soit
résorbée alors pas de pénurie donc mes
détention temporaires c'est important
les mots et on sait bien que celui de
pénurie il est interdit au sommet de
l'État il est interdit exécutif parce
que on est en plein de plantes sobriété
il y a des inquiétudes sur le gaz on
veut pas parler de pénurie donc pénurie
on le dit pas vendredi petit changement
de braquet dans les fils
d'automobilistes qui s'allonge quand
même dans les hauts de France en
Île-de-France Olivier Véran parle de
difficultés en privé le porte-parole du
gouvernement pèse contre la panique des
hommes automobilistes qu'il compare à
celle des Français au moment du
confinement avec le papier toilette
l'idée il a pu en avoir donc il y en a
plus et en déplacement Alger Elizabeth
borne promet des améliorations pardon
pour sortir de ces difficultés on est
toujours dans les difficultés or ce
matin vous avez montré les chiffres la
moitié des stations étaient en rupture
de stock dans les hauts de France et en
Île-de-France quand on calcule ça fait
quand même deux régions qui regroupent à
elle seule 18 millions d'habitants c'est
un Français sur 4 et on rappelle quand
même que le mot pénurie ça veut dire le
manque de ce qui est nécessaire et là on
est très clairement en situation de
pénurie même si le gouvernement
joue un peu avec les mots dans ces deux
régions là c'est la pénurie et alors
donc sur la temporalité vous dites que
le gouvernement a tardé à réagir oui
alors faut reconnaître la décharge
exécutive que c'est pas facile vous
l'avez dit d'abord parce que c'est un
conflit du secteur privé qui oppose une
direction et des salariés dans un
secteur privé l'État n'a pas beaucoup la
main sur ce qui se passe dans
l'entreprise il peut légiférer mais pas
intervenir comme ça directement il y a
il y a pas beaucoup d'armes non plus il
y a les préfets on l'a dit qu'ils
peuvent éventuellement recouvrir la
force soit pour débloquer les sistes
soit pour réquisitionner de la main
d'oeuvre des salariés sur place mais
dans les deux cas ils ne le font qu'en
cas de force majeure j'allais dire et
que pour garantir un service minimum
c'est-à-dire pour assurer la livraison
et la distribution d'essence pour les
véhicules d'urgence pas pour un retour à
la normale pour pour tous les Français
et puis enfin l'état on avait une arme
c'était les fameuses réserves
stratégiques mais là encore ça a été
débloqué trop tard puis quand même je
reviens à ce que disait vérin quand je
vais pas citer Camus pas mal nommé les
choses s'ajouter au malheur du monde
parce qu'on parle d'un plein d'essence
donc c'est pas non plus peut-être un peu
tout match mais quand même quand vous
donnez le sentiment de nier ce que
vivent les gens sur un sujet vous avez
dit inflammable moi je dis explosif que
le carburant j'ai un souvenez-vous les
gilets jaunes et puis ça touche aussi la
liberté d'aller venir pour les Français
ça le confinement on a l'impression que
les choses se répètent un peu comme
allez vous faire vacciner mais il y a
pas de vaccin mais si on vous dit qu'il
y en a et voilà on est toujours dans
cette espèce de déni de réalité et alors
je le disais en titre le prix dans la
République s'en mêle oui du coup ce
matin l'Elysée a fait savoir qu'il
allait reprendre le dossier en main
c'est en tout cas le signe que le
gouvernement s'est montré défaillant on
verra bien ce que fait Emmanuel Macron
qui souhaitait mettre la pression sur
les syndicats les directions de
raffineur mais c'est pas évident écoutez
ce qu'il a dit cet après-midi et
souhaite que dans les prochaines heures
et les tous prochains dans les
prochaines heures et au plus vite il y a
une issue qui soit trouvée à cela mais
vous comprendrez aisément que on va pas
rentrer dans une situation c'est le
président de la République qui va faire
les négociations salariales chez Esso
total parce que là on va partir cul par
dessus tête hein et ben voilà on va on
va partir super de suite le président de
la République fait les négociations chez
Total ce qui montre bien que c'est un
job dont il se serait visiblement bien
passé mais voilà je la trouve assez
symbolique cette gestion de crise de la
façon dont cette exécutif exerce le
pouvoir y compris lors du précédent
quinquennat cul par du sucette c'est
drôle Émilie on retrouve les le sens des
expressions un peu surnés
Emmanuel Macron également ça c'était
pour les huberts c'est
uber le dossier non ce que je trouve
c'est on sent qu'il y a une espèce de
pression qui monte et il y a le 16
octobre quand même il y a la marche
contre la vie chère et on voit bien que
jusqu'à maintenant les citoyens les gens
sont plutôt préoccupés par leur
portefeuille peut-être que justement
cette histoire de carburant qui était
très concrète c'est à dire qu'on voit
les files d'attente on voit les
énervements on voit ce que ça empêche de
faire c'est très concret et peut-être
que ça sera la goutte d'eau
supplémentaire qui fait que d'un coup il
y a pas la révolution mais en tout cas
il y a une envie un petit peu de montrer
sur mes contentement et cette espèce de
colère qu'on sent depuis longtemps juste
pour revenir sur les négociations moi je
pense que c'est
et je pense que le gouvernement a passé
de vision un petit peu moyen ou long
terme on a changé de modèle au niveau du
travail on a changé depuis le covid un
rapport de travail complètement
différent qui est pas du tout appréhendé
et ça c'est conditions de travail ça
fait partie de ce changement de rapport
au travail et il y a certaines
entreprises je sais pas Carrefour Airbus
Air France qui ont anticipé ça et qui
ont déjà balancé les augmentations de
salaire dans une négociation qui se
passe quand même relativement bien un
dialogue social
pour les salariés mais totalement ils se
rendent pas compte de ce qui se passe
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui et je pense
que c'est la même chose pour la
transition énergétique
allumage en retard mais en retard qui
risque de nous coûter très cher
vous allez me suivre en régie ce
communiqué de Total puisqu'on parle
justement des salaires des des ouvriers
et des et des eaux alors le terme c'est
c'est opérateur
opérateur de raffinerie je crois que
c'est le terme qui est employé par par
Total je suis en train de rechercher
Bala voilà donc voilà avec mes yeux je
peux pas le lire
mais vous vous êtes en train de le lire
grâce à moi donc le prix moyen je l'ai
pas là mais bon c'est pas grave ah voilà
je
l'ai trouvé
des lunettes pour lire les infographies
donc 9000 euros ça c'est l'intéressement
7250 au montant minimum rémunération
moyenne d'un opérateur de raffinerie en
2022 5000 € par mois intéressants
participation compris Catherine tricot
je voyais réagir parce que alors c'est
sous-entendu ben on est bien au-delà du
salaire médian on est dans la France
riche enfin voilà 5000 euros par mois la
chronique de Dominique ce sur France
Inter a fait quand même grand bruit
parce que justement il a repris tel quel
se communiquer alors que les syndicats
contestent ces chiffres donc déjà on
pourrait au moins avoir un regard
contrarié enfin
contradictoire la CGT dit c'est 3000
euros et pas 5000 euros donc par
ailleurs on ne nous parle pas du patron
est-ce que c'est avec prix mais est-ce
que c'est salaire moyen bref chacun doit
pouvoir sortir le chiffre et puis il
arrange mais même 3000 euros par rapport
à la moyenne des Français c'est beaucoup
on est bien d'accord on est d'accord
c'est plus que la moyenne des Français
donc confère la discussion de tout à
l'heure c'est en fait les salaires en
France ont beaucoup beaucoup reculé
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait les gens gagnent
trop mal leur vie aujourd'hui donc 3000
euros avant c'était le salaire d'un prof
et aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le salaire
d'un prof donc 3000 euros à Paris comme
mère et fille quand ce n'est cette un
salaire qui peine à vous faire vivre en
région parisienne en tout cas je veux
dire avec le prix des loyers des
transports et cetera mais par ailleurs
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est que
on communique sur le salaire enfin les
le salaire du patron qui de Total qui
s'est augmenté lui de 52% et qu'il ne
gagne que je vais rappeler comment ça
marche attendez je vais rappeler comment
ça marche juste pour consacrer
variable d'accord et bien alors il y a
les bons résultats donc la part variable
augmente et ensuite c'est voter en
assemblée générale par les actionnaires
actionnaire à qui il y a eu beaucoup
d'argent distribués aussi tout ça peut
marcher ensemble mais voilà comment ça
marche
que lui il a bénéficier il y a des
patrons qui l'ont fait il y a même des
patrons qui ont décidé de de de de
donner leur boîte à des fondations le
patron de patagoniens
une augmentation de ses revenus de 52%.
donc je veux dire c'est pas lui qui l'a
décidé mais n'empêche qu'il a bénéficié
de ça alors qu'on refuse les 10 % au
reste des salariés et enfin dernier
petit point que je voulais dire c'est
que je pense que si c'est un problème
qui devient un problème politique c'est
qu'en fait il y a eu un débat politique
sur qu'est-ce qu'on fait des supers
profits total est une entreprise
symbolique de la France c'est la
multinationale française voilà qui a
passé et passé ces bénéfices de 7
milliards en 2021 en 2020 à un premier
semestre 1er semestre 2021 de 7
milliards à 20 milliards en 2022 donc
non mais ça veut dire que 2022 autant
que sur le ils ont fait trois fois oui
trois fois le premier semestre autant
que sur toute l'année bref
il y a des pays se réjouit quand une
entreprise gagne beaucoup d'argent mais
mais je suis d'accord avec vous sur la
redistribution de la richesse c'est un
vrai débat c'est pas simplement la
redistribution avec les salariés c'est
que les supers profits cantés mais la
demande de taxer des supers produits
c'est aussi pour parce que le pays en a
besoin pour faire sa transition
énergétique pas rester dans les caisses
de
c'est pourquoi je je peux en placer une
parce que c'est compliqué c'est Dame
mais c'est très bien c'est messieurs moi
aussi j'arrête pas d'intervenir
c'est pourquoi je pense on est là c'est
ça qui est intéressant dans ce conflit
c'est une révolution culturelle qui est
en train de se faire je veux dire que ce
qui compte dans ce conflit c'est ça
c'est pas tellement les réticences du
patron de Total et le jeu un peu
politique reconnaissons malgré tout de
la CGT c'est quelque part que se joue
justement de la part des des salariés
l'exigence d'avoir une répartition
beaucoup plus équitable des bénéfices
d'une entreprise on a oublié de parler
des des actionnaires parce que là aussi
il y a des actionnaires sont eux qui ont
quand même réalisé des bénéfices très
importants donc il y a aujourd'hui et
dans toute la dans toutes les
entreprises parce que il y a eu le
télétravail parce que il y a une
surinflation qui revient etc et que la
question du pouvoir d'achat est revenue
au premier plan elle l'avait-elle quitté
d'ailleurs on nous avait un peu baladé
avec la sécurité le pouvoir d'achat a
toujours été la
le sujet des Français mais ce qui moi ce
qui me semble très intéressant c'est que
voilà maintenant les les salariés et
travailleurs ne veulent plus se laisser
et je dirais
être les dindons de la farce de la
redistribution ça c'est quelque chose
qui est quand même assez nouveau et
c'est un enjeu profond et sociétal et je
pense que le gouvernement avait plutôt
ciblé sur l'intéressement un peu à la de
Gaulle c'est-à-dire on favorise ça
d'ailleurs il l'avait annoncé Emmanuel
Macron va essayer de faciliter pour que
les entreprises mais quelque part ça
parle moins c'est quelque chose de plus
abstrait que son salaire et le côté
pérenne en fait je pense que ça ça a pas
le même poids ça a pas la même valeur
pour un salarié d'avoir un intéressement
choisi ou alors d'avoir son salaire qui
augmente je pense que là-dessus ça va
être compliqué
mais je pense que la question de fond
que le gouvernement aborde très peu et
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure le plan
de sobriété il est quand même on s'est
c'est on règle la question urgente de
passer en hiver voire deux hivers en
baissant de chauffage il y avait pas
tellement de projections sur la
transition écologique la question au
fond de tout ça est-ce que vous avez dit
Catherine c'est la financement de la
transition énergétique et pour l'instant
on s'y prend un peu comme des manches
parce que on met un bouclier tarifaire
ce qui fait qu'on pourrait on paye moins
cher une énergie fossile dont on veut se
séparer et on n'arrive pas à profiter de
l'argent à masser par ces énergéticiens
qui pourraient et d'ailleurs total le
fait il faut pas il faut pas mentir non
plus total investi dans la transition
énergétique de plus en plus dans les
énergies renouvelables il y a des
projets d'éoliennes qui se font mais on
pourrait peut-être un petit peu les
taxer davantage et je pense que cette
question là elle est pas du tout faite
et derrière cette question il y a l'idée
de se dire un bouquet tarifaire pour une
oui pour une énergie fossile dont on
veut se passer c'est pas bien c'est pas
c'est pas intelligent mais par contre il
faut protéger les plus modestes
pour financer la transition écologique
quand on fait une taxe carbone quand on
fait juste tout le monde crie et ouais
tout le monde dit il est hors de
question que moi je parle des français
quand on fait des taxes carbone tout le
monde tout le monde crie ou quand si on
a augmenté le prix du carburant tout le
monde crierait et quand on indemnise les
Français parce que les prix augmentent
on crie aussi il y a on est quand même
assez contradictoires et ambivalent sur
cette question après la question des
surpères profits oui elle se pose quand
on entend la défense de Patrick puyannet
qui dit oui mais je paye des impôts en
France je paye mes taxes sociales non il
paye des cotisations sociales comme tout
bon employeur c'est pas un geste qui
fait simplement il y a un système fiscal
on en a déjà parlé sur ce plateau
plusieurs fois qui fait que l'impôt il
est territorialisé il est il est payé en
gros dans les pays où il explore et où
le produit du pétrole et non pas en
France comme le raffinage sont assez peu
bénéficiaires par rapport à
l'exploration de production faut le dire
donc voilà après on pourrait imaginer
avoir un fond d'investissement Emmanuel
Macron c'est un entrepreneur c'est la
startup nation on peut imaginer que les
entreprises investissent il y a la
distribution des richesses au sein des
entreprises mais il y a aussi
l'investissement on pourrait les forcer
les fléchies sur une transition
énergétique enfin je veux dire il y a
des possibilités
c'est de l'investissement
dans un bâtiment collectif l'isolation
thermique d'un logement c'est 25000
euros
connaissez bien je le dis pour noter les
spectateurs qui ne savent pas forcément
parce que vous êtes architecte tout à
fait donc vous connaissez vraiment bien
le le prix de aujourd'hui l'État a
provisionné deux milliards 5 ça veut
dire qu'il approvisionné pour
l'isolation de 100000 logements on a 37
millions de logements en France donc la
moitié pratiquement sont dans les les
étiquettes les plus basses ce que je
veux dire c'est que ne serait-ce que les
8 milliards qui ont été versés aux
actionnaires je dis pas qu'il faut tout
leur prendre mais on en prendrait la
moitié et on mettrait ces 4 milliards en
partie pour faire de l'énergie
renouvelable de l'hydrogène et pour
isoler pour multiplier par deux les
subventions accordées pour isoler les
logements c'est-à-dire c'est pas ça
irait plus vite et ça fait non mais non
mais ce que j'ai oui mais c'est un
conseil constitutionnel il y a l'égalité
devant l'impôt
vous comptez payer total plutôt que
d'autres filles il y a une vraie
question pas que des questions
techniques ce sont aussi des questions
qui peuvent se
dire et totalement ne peut pas avoir de
des supers profits en plus accumuler une
rampe de situation qu'il va augmenter
c'est-à-dire que lui il fait des
investissements qui vont conforter sa
position oligarchique enfin je veux dire
sa position
à la concurrence internationale il y a
pas que total sur le marché des des
hydrocarbures et des énergies
renouvelables bref ça se dit pas qu'il
faut tout prendre mais je pense que ça
se discute aussi la question de la de la
des économies de l'attractivité d'un
pays il faut aussi garder ça en tête là
quand on prend sur mesure à l'échelle
franco-française c'est ça la question
que je me pose question européenne ça
c'est pas très très bien passé on va
dire que le marché de le marché de
l'énergie le marché de l'énergie à
l'échelle européenne il a surtout
conduit à mettre EDF sur le flanc donc
on peut non mais en ce moment oui ça
serait bien de changer mais personne n'a
analyse vraiment la situation
de la concurrence européenne et de ce
qui se passe dans les autres pays
européens oui c'est si vous si vous
prenons Monsieur Patrick pouyanet elle a
voulu vous le vous le taxer de manière
outrancière il va aller ailleurs ou
alors les les capitaux vont se déplacer
ailleurs où vous vous pouvez attendre je
peux faire son travail à moins cher
en plus je connais pas ce monsieur
est-ce que je veux dire
est-ce que c'est légitime 6 millions
d'euros par mois franchement alors ça
c'est un autre débat c'est sur le le
patron qu'un vrai un vrai bon débat mais
encore plein de thèmes que
oui
les salaires des patrons est-ce qu'on
peut se payer les meilleurs patrons bon
moins cher etc c'est un autre débat
Catherine qu'on fera une fois sur ce
plateau je vous le promets et on vous
invitera parce que je le trouve très
intéressant je trouve très intéressant
allez je reprends un peu la main c'est
c'est un débat passionnant tout le monde
a envie de parler en même temps
peut-être pour revoir un peu comment
l'exécutif communique depuis ce matin je
trouve que c'est quand même assez
intéressant donc il y a une double
séquence il y a d'abord la première
ministre Isabelle borne vous le savez
est en déplacement en Algérie et depuis
Alger elle donne une interview à nos
confrères de RTL pour dire ce
moi j'ai vraiment invité les directions
et les représentants des salariés à la
fois des sceaux et de Total à se mettre
autour de la table il y a des blocages
qui sont liés à des attentes salariales
de la part donc des salariés je pense
que tout ça doit se faire dans la
discussion dans la négociation moi je
compte sur la direction et les
représentants des salariés pour trouver
des accords et arrêter les blocages qui
pénalisent les Français donc là on est
dans une logique d'ailleurs elle si
totale et Esso pour pas s'entraîner le
débat sur total donc c'est c'est aux
partenaire sociaux de trouver la
solution ensuite Emmanuel Macron on en a
vu un autre extrait dans votre édito
tout à l'heure Mathieu Emmanuel Macron
qui est un peu sur la même ligne écouter
le gouvernement prend sa part en mettant
la pression pour que les négociations
aboutissent au plus vite mais faut que
les parties prenantes prennent leur
responsabilités les entreprises et les
chefs d'entreprise concernées et les
syndicats concernés le blocage c'est pas
une façon de négocier le blocage c'est
pas une façon de
négocier et il a dit dans cette
interview aussi Emmanuel Macron que les
négociations étaient en bonne voie mise
à part ce qui si on si on parle de
communication politique il prend quand
même un sacré risque parce que Ben en
l'occurrence la grève a été reconduite
et il a certainement des informations
qu'on a pas mais il prend un risque mais
oui bien sûr il prend un risque et puis
c'est quand même un petit peu gonflé de
dire la pression enfin de faire la
pression bah c'est voilà quand on fait
une grève ou quand on fait une
manifestation on va pas demander
l'autorisation voilà c'est préventif
c'est peut-être ça qui choque mais il y
a quand même l'idée de bloquer ok mais
tous les syndicats ils sont pas d'accord
tiens écoute Laurent Berger qui leur
donne la parole juste après Laurent
Berger secrétaire général de la CFDT
évidemment
la CFD elle est pas tellement pour les
greffes préventives elle est pour agir
au moment où on discute sur sur le sujet
il y a deux il y a deux problèmes il y a
trois problèmes sur les problèmes
d'approvisionnement je crois qu'il faut
se dire le premier c'est évidemment
c'est être grève qui est une grève alors
que il y a des négociations qui doivent
s'ouvrir et et on a le rapport de force
nécessaire pour pour imposer des
augmentations notamment à total le
deuxième et ça s'ouvre encore le 15
novembre il y a eu un accord de branche
qui faisait un plancher et qui va
s'augmenter qui va augmenter qu'on avait
pas besoin de cette grève non je crois
ouais j'assume ça et mes copains mes
collègues de Total et des sols assument
donc pardon et finalement ça ouvre la
question elle est un peu abordée est-ce
que c'est une grève politique de la part
de la CGT avec cette idée de faire la
jonction avec le la manifestation le
mouvement samedi probablement et on voit
que d'ailleurs ils ont recentré la
question sur les salaires complètement
il y a eu un communiqué de la CGT en
disant bon ben voilà on est d'accord
pour négocier que sur ça total a l'air
d'accord donc ça avance quand même
évidemment que c'est pour mettre ce
sujet sur la table et comme on disait
c'est quelque chose qui qui rôde depuis
longtemps l'augmentation des salaires et
cela c'est une opportunité terrible pour
y aller je pense qu'il y a aussi la
question peut-être en sous-main du
gouvernement peut-être qui commence à
obtenir des des informations de la part
de Total parce qu'on est quand même en
discussion budgétaire et on l'a dit tout
à l'heure il y a la taxe sur les super
profits qui est quand même en question
est-ce que c'est pas aussi un moyen de
dire total bon bah voilà il vaut mieux
vaut lâcher un petit peu sur
l'augmentation des salaires et puis nous
peut-être je sais pas à droite et droite
et extrême droite on peut essayer de
d'éviter que la taxe sur les super
profits je sais pas il peut y avoir
aussi des négociations comme ça en tout
cas c'est vrai que le ton d'Emmanuel
Macron qui a voulu prendre un peu de
hauteur de vue en disant parce que quand
même il s'occupe de toutes les affaires
mais là il veut pas s'en occuper mais il
a été de plus en plus positif donc à les
négociations qui sont en bonne voie
c'est assez étrange puisque hier les
syndicats disaient qu'il n'était
toujours pas en contact avec la
direction de de total donc si hier il y
avait toujours pas de prise de contact
entre les syndicats et la direction
totale on peut pas imaginer que le lundi
des négociations soient déjà en bonne
voie enfin je veux dire au moins qui se
soit rencontré qu'il se rend compte
qu'il ne semble pas encore invinci la
question qui est toujours intéressante
du du des salariés qui ont le pouvoir de
blocage
on cite souvent les aiguilleurs du ciel
on pourrait citer les cheminots etc etc
est-ce qu'ils vont est-ce qu'ils font
grève pour eux ou pour les autres un peu
les deux pour tous les autres toujours
pour eux toujours ils le font pour eux
mais s'ils sont soutenus si aujourd'hui
la dame
la possibilité d'avoir des augmentations
de salaire parce que on le dit total a
fait de bénéfices colossaux et dans les
milieux très syndic très syndiqués comme
l'industrie est quand même plus indiquée
et les raffineries quand même plus
indiqués c'est comme les dockers enfin
voilà il y a des il y a des bastions
syndiqués et bien on a un rapport de
force qui est plus favorable salarié et
c'est une grève préventive pour mettre
la pression sur le patronat c'est un
grand classique alors on peut en penser
ce qu'on en veut certains trouve que
c'est une bonne idée de faire pression
avant les négo d'autres comme Laurent
Berger disent c'est quand même absurde
ce dialogue social à la française on
commence par montrer ses muscles avant
de discuter il se battent évidemment
pour eux les syndicats et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on leur reproche quand
on voit le taux de syndiqué en France
c'est ils ont toujours fait la
préférence pour les salariés
ensuite on parle des stocks stratégiques
oui non je pense que c'était évident
qu'il se battent pour eux mais c'est
évident que si ils ont si ça peut tenir
c'est aussi parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
France contre eux et c'est une certaine
manière on a de bannières réitérer ce
phénomène cette cet événement qui se
produit quelqu'un fait grève et en fait
le reste de la France bah finalement
soutien ou ne s'oppose pas parce qu'ils
savent bien que eux c'est vrai qu'ils
gagnent plus que la plupart des Français
perds qui sont dans une situation de
rapport de force qui leur est favorable
mais que d'une certaine manière il
continue de maintenir un standard en
disant ce n'est pas c'est pas anormal de
gagner 3000 euros par mois quand on fait
les trois huit et que on est un ouvrier
qualifié donc voilà ils ont ils
continuent de maintenir un standard
essaye tout le monde
rappeler que la CGT elle est quand même
dans une stratégie de conflictualité
puisque elle était depuis quelques
années dépassée par la CFDT qui est une
autre stratégie qui à mon sens est plus
en adéquation avec ce qui se fait
ailleurs en Europe voilà
un tordre le cou l'idée que la CGT le
fait pour le 16 octobre parce qu'il faut
quand même rappeler que
Martinez pas voulu appeler à manifester
le 16 octobre donc il y a pas de grandes
coalition de complot
la réforme des retraites on parlait tout
à l'heure de 2010 il y a eu une pénurie
il y a eu ces problèmes de stations
il y a une un problème sur les stations
services et parce que il y avait en 2010
cette réforme des retraites en fait ce
que je veux dire c'est que ça rejoint
quelque part il y a beaucoup de
préoccupations sociales qui peuvent au
bout d'un moment se rejoindre on n'a pas
encore attaqué les négociations enfin si
ça va s'attaquer demain mais par les
syndicats je pense plus d'abord alors
salaire que à la réforme des retraites
il nous reste une douzaine de minutes
j'aurais qu'on parle des des leviers que
le gouvernement peut activer vous l'avez
évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure Mathieu
la question des réserves stratégiques
Samia de chier vous pouvez nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau bonsoir Samia
bienvenue alors de quoi on parle c'est
quoi ces réserves stratégiques alors
c'est en stock un stock qui correspond à
90 jours de consommation dans notre pays
c'est-à-dire à peu près 3 mois pour la
France donc ça représente environ 18
millions de tonnes de carburant et c'est
une obligation pour les entreprises
elles doivent s'organiser pour assurer
que ce stock soit disponible ça date
d'une loi qui a été votée en 1928 à
l'époque où on est en train de tirer les
leçons un peu de la Première Guerre
mondiale et pendant laquelle d'ailleurs
on a bien failli manquer de pétrole et
on réalise donc que c'est une ressource
stratégique et pas seulement pour faire
la guerre mais aussi tout simplement
pour faire tourner le pays d'où cette
loi qui a été votée à l'époque alors je
précise quand même que ce stock
stratégique il est censé uniquement
servir à un usage civil un Thomas pour
l'armée il y a d'autres réserves de
pétrole et alors où sont stockés ces 18
millions de tonnes de carburant parce
que ça fait quand même une sacrée
quantité la majeure partie elle est
stock sur un site à Manosque c'est une
zone du Parc Naturel du Lubéron où se
trouve 30 cavités salines qui peuvent
stocker jusqu'à 9 millions de mètres
cubes de pétrole les réserves
stratégiques elles sont aussi stockées
dans les 8 raffineries que compte la
France et enfin dans 80 dépôts
commerciaux qui eux sont répartis sur
tout le territoire alors c'est des
opérateurs je disais de constituer ces
stocks mais seul l'état peut décider de
les débloquer comme ça a été le cas déjà
en 2016 là aussi en raison de grève dans
une raffinerie à l'époque on avait
débloqué l'équivalent de trois jours de
consommation de pétrole dans notre pays
et plus récemment on le sait moins mais
début 2022 au moment de la du
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine à
la demande de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie la France a également libéré
une partie de ses réserves stratégiques
de pétrole avec un but c'était de
limiter l'augmentation des prix merci
beaucoup merci Samia je me tourne vers
Patrice Geoffron qui est avec nous en
duplex en visioconférence professeure
d'économie à Paris Dauphine directeur du
centre de géopolitique de l'énergie et
des matières premières bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
peut-être un mot sur ces stocks
stratégiques ils sont très rapidement
des blocables c'est-à-dire que quand le
gouvernement dit on débloque ça peut
être dans les stations services en quoi
24 48 heures c'est rapide ça
oui derrière tout ça il y a de la
logistique donc ça peut prendre
évidemment un peu de temps on le
constate à l'heure actuelle le petit le
problème n'a pas été résolu
instantanément sur la base de la
décision qui a été annoncée par la
première ministre et notamment dans la
partie nord de la de la France donc faut
imaginer qu'à la fois la question de
l'accès au stock qu'ils ont très
largement répartis sur le territoire et
plutôt maillé il y a la disponibilité
évidemment des capacités de transport
donc ça suppose évidemment d'avoir des
camions qui soient adaptés et puis
d'avoir des chauffeurs et puis
évidemment de parvenir à rattraper le
retard qui a été accumulé au cours des
10 derniers jours donc évidemment tout
ça n'est pas instantané et puis par
ailleurs il s'agit avec ces stocks
stratégiques de répondre à une partie de
l'inquiétude de nos concitoyens et se
faisant de s'efforcer finalement
d'éviter l'afflux à la pompe telle qu'on
l'a vu ce weekend voilà de quelle
manière envoyer un signal disons
d'attente à minima et faire en sorte
qu'il serait la vraie difficulté que les
professions essentielles et on peut
penser évidemment aux professions
médicales se trouvent et puis par
ailleurs évidemment aux artisans à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens qui ont
des obligations qui n'ont pas
nécessairement la la totalité des
ménages voilà ne se retrouve pas face à
une réelle pénurie donc on est à ce
point de tension d'où la décision de la
première ministre d'ailleurs information
de cette fin d'après-midi donnée par nos
confrères du Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France l'interdiction de remplir des
géricens c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de
vues dans le dans les stations services
on fait le plein et puis qui ont trois
ou quatre jerrican dans le coffre et qui
bref pour ceux qui font la queue depuis
trois quarts d'heure et qui arrivent et
que la porte se ferme c'est un peu
agaçant mais on peut comprendre le
réflexe mais tout ça c'est interdit ça a
été annoncé en cette fin d'après-midi en
tout cas révélée par nos confrères du
Parisien j'ai une autre question pour
vous Patrice geoffront sur donc là ça
c'était pour les stocks la stratégique
mais il y a aussi des d'autres moyens
d'importer du carburant déjà raffiné et
donc ça j'imagine que c'est aussi en
cours est-ce que c'est si facile que ça
alors c'est également en cours après il
y a des délais naturellement
d'acheminement suppose soit les
acheminer jusque différents ports
d'importation soit d'acheminer également
mais par voie terrestres cette fois du
pétrole enfin des produits pétroliers
plutôt et ça c'est en cours en
provenance du Benelux il y a une autre
voie d'acheminement elle fluviale
notamment par le Rhin voilà donc ce qui
donne à la fois une j'allais dire une
perspective géographique sur les
solutions de repli mais ce qui dans
chaque cas permet de comprendre un peu
la logistique sous-jacente et puis le
fait que à l'évidence tout ça va prendre
au minimum quelques jours et dernière
question qui prend cette décision sur
les le fait d'importer du carburant déjà
raffiné c'est l'état ce sont les
opérateurs enfin ce sont les les
compagnies pétrolières c'est-à-dire
total Epson et les autres
des choses différentes par rapport à
votre première question sur les stocks
stratégiques et bien c'est régalien et
ça a été dit par votre journaliste et
puis par ailleurs concernant et bien la
nécessité d'approvisionnement là on a de
la coordination plus haut niveau entre
les autorités publiques schématiquement
et puis par ailleurs les opérateurs
voilà qui ont intérêt évidemment à ce
qu'il a gardé une activité dans leur
point de distribution et donc à trouver
pour ça des solutions de repli merci
beaucoup merci Patrice geoffront pour
pour cette éclairage j'ai l'impression
Jean Gary qui c'est une espèce de course
contre la montre quoi entre entre voilà
c'est inquiétude certains hispaniques
qui gagnent de nombreux Français qui est
voilà on est on a tous passé du temps ce
week-end pour ceux qui roulent en
voiture essayer de trouver du carburant
et puis ce gouvernement qui cherche par
remplir les cuves par tous les moyens
oui parce que on est toujours dans cet
équilibre fragile entre la psychologie
des foules les mentalités la manière
dans les gens perçoivent une réalité et
cette réalité que les politiques ont à
gérer mais à travers leur communication
parce qu'on voit très bien là le tous
les effets de posture on a parlé avec
les ébots de bornes Emmanuel Macron donc
c'est finalement la vérité personne ne
la sait personne ne l'a dit
véritablement mais on a quelque chose
qui qui s'appelle la gouvernance et qui
est confronté justement à ces phénomène
irrationnels qui qui sont les nôtres et
qui sont de plus en plus difficiles à
gérer dans notre société avec les
réseaux sociaux la surinformation
l'immédiateté de l'information qui qui
décuple tous ces tous ces tous ces
réflexes ils appellenti il y a ce soir
21h à Matignon une réunion de de crise
Élisabeth borne qui convoque 4 de ces
ministres en creux ça ressemble quand
même un peu à une une reprise en main
on sent au fil des jours quand même
cette idée que probablement la
communication a été assez déplorable et
il y a eu un espèce de déni de la
réalité et on cette reprise en main ce
que je trouve intéressant c'est que ça
ressemble quand on voit là vous parliez
de cette interdiction de remplir des
jerrican on est sur ça me fait penser au
covid on était sur l'attestation il y a
toujours les mêmes problèmes qui se
posent de logistique le professeur en
économie il a dit on a toujours un
problème de logistique en France les
vaccins c'était la même chose là c'est
ramener de l'essence les masques et on a
cette question de est-ce qu'on interdit
est-ce qu'on arrive à négocier comment
on traite la population est-ce que c'est
la responsabilité ou bien c'est un état
un peu autoritaire qui disent qu'il faut
faire ou pas faire je trouve que c'est
quand même intéressant et responsable
exactement donc ça amène après on espère
que ça va pouvoir se résoudre mais ça va
être
en tout cas ça module le propos du
président quand il dit on n'a pas
intervenir là on voit bien que s'il faut
qu'ils interviennent c'est à dire qu'en
fait c'est une question stratégique et
la deuxième question que ça pose c'est
qu'on voit à quel point notre pays est
dépendant
au pétrole et que vraiment là il le sait
ça devient une question politique
majeure comment on s'en sort comment on
fait émerger des alternatives à se tout
pétrole qui qui nous rend fragile et le
si on parle des leviers que le
gouvernement peut actionner il y a aussi
on l'a évoqué très rapidement et à la
manière forte c'est ce que réclame la
CPME qui regroupe je le rappelle 200
43000 TPE petite entreprise PME et ETI
entreprise de taille intermédiaire
regardez ce communiqué il convient que
les pouvoirs publics et en particulier
les préfets assument les responsabilités
qui leur incombe en prenant les mesures
y compris juridiques telles que
réquisition pour assurer le
fonctionnement normal des raffineries la
Catrice reste avec vous parce que il y a
sans doute cette tentation on évoquait
c'était 2010 octobre 2010 c'est presque
à presque la même date c'était le 19
octobre 2010 quand Nicolas Sarkozy
décide d'actionnés ce levier de la de la
réquisition
il y a un risque politique qui est
exactement c'est pas le même climat
aujourd'hui celui de 2010 même si on
était en pleine
en pleine plein mouvement des retraites
oui mais là on est dans un moment
vraiment de grande inquiétude sociale et
je pense que le gouvernement va y
réfléchir à deux fois avant de d'abord
parce que ça peut provoquer un effet en
chêne dans d'autres secteurs de
solidarisation avec le fait de faire de
passer en force là il faut que il faut
que la négociation s'ouvre et que ils
aboutissent à une solution mais surtout
c'est que on a une inquiétude ça
rencontre encore une fois ce que je
voulais dire tout à l'heure c'est que ça
rencontre une inquiétude partagée par
les Français face à l'inflation et face
aux petits salaires et que donc on peut
pas y aller frontalement et brutalement
au départ de l'opinion publique qui
demande un peu de poids une face à comme
celle-là c'est possible mais je pense
que c'est pour ça que c'est une question
qui est délicate et que pour l'instant
ce qu'ils essayent de faire c'est de
régler le problème voilà faire aboutir
les négociations et libérer les stocks
stratégiques ce risque politique ça
ajoute un risque juridique puisque après
il peut y avoir l'étape on se retrouve
en procès pour avoir remis en cause le
droit de grève et ça passer au Conseil
d'État et du coup la décision la
décision pourrait être là aussi un peu
au coeur de l'archipel français parce
que vous avez comme ça des intérêts
catégoriels qui s'opposent des groupes
sociaux qui qui s'opposent clairement et
ça on est vraiment au cœur de nos
problématiques et qui explique aussi
d'ailleurs la fragmentation de notre
espace politique dire que là aussi ce
conflit il est assez exemplaire est-ce
qu'on voit très bien que il peut y avoir
une solidarisation d'une partie des
salariés par rapport au combat que même
les gens de chez Total mais pour
d'autres organisations d'autres groupes
d'autres catégories sociales ça peut se
passer d'une autre manière voilà et moi
je trouve que ça ressemble beaucoup à
notre paysage politique merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat Jean je vais rappeler le
titre de votre tout nouveau livre Élisée
contre je le place où ici Elisée contre
Matignon c'est publié aux éditions
talendier le couple infernal de 1958 à
nos jours merci encore à tous les trois